big thank you to dungeon Fighter online
for sponsoring today's video Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen zero is one of the highest
grossing anime films ever released and
my first time ever hearing about it was
today in 2022 Jiu Jitsu Kaizen was the
single highest selling Series in Japan
period besting even one piece and to
this day it remains one of the most
popular ongoing stories in circulation
with over 70 million copies sold as of
writing this video and somehow I made it
to 2023 without even knowing so much as
how to spell the title until now
so now that I'm a spelling expert I
figured what better way to spend my
weekend than By ignoring all of my
friends and family and Diving instead
headfirst into this weird Japanese film
about Sorcerers fighting curse monsters
and anthropomorphized Panda Warriors
doing all sorts of crazy stuff without
people seeming to battle knife seriously
this dude straight up just appears on
screen walking around talking as if
nothing is going and this dude just
chatting about mayonnaise or some [__] I
don't know what's going on but I digress
I'm watching this film to help me
determine whether or not I'd be
interested in the future with reviewing
the greater series someday of Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen so with that out of the way let's
see if this movie was any good
foreign
[Music]
I've watched the film and I have a lot
to say but in short what did I think of
it
yeah I thought it was okay I guess some
parts were better than others and I
thought I had some structural issues but
I can see why some folks like it fine
enough I guess okay if that felt a
little lukewarm for those of you that
are massive fans of the series I think I
have my reasons for feeling this way
that might also justify your own
feelings towards too for those of you
that don't know this film is an
adaptation of a single volume of manga
initially released in 2017 one year
before the main series that alone is
weird but it also means the manga of the
story was actually released before the
main series began and became popular
after 2018 and so naturally because a
lot of folks don't read manga this story
might have only reached you guys after
having seen the series already with you
already having an appreciation for this
world and its characters and needless to
say just like all the folks who picked
up this story in the spring and summer
of 2017 in Japan this was my first
exposure to Jiu Jitsu Kaizen also which
might explain my impression of the film
and why they are likely a little
different to you and many others and so
given that this manga and companion film
were indeed my first introduction to the
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen World here are my
honest thoughts on the story I saw
narratively while this story works well
enough has some likable characters and
plays with some interesting narrative
and visual ideas here and there I think
my main takeaway from the film is that
it felt rather
uninspired however even in my very own
work server there are those that both
agree and disagree with me on this so
I'm going to do my best to explain where
I'm coming from and Grant concessions
where I feel they're warranted so let's
go through the film piece by piece the
introduction the character of Utah and
indeed the situation he finds himself
trapped within is effectively the pillar
upon which this entire film is balanced
and conceptually I think Utah and the
Kersey has to live with is the single
most fascinating ruffle in this story
and I don't mean that in a disparaging
way either it's a great idea with his
former childhood sweetheart having
promised herself to marry him when they
were older only for her to suddenly die
and now effectively haunt him in a
defensive manner it is on its face a
compelling and emotionally complicated
situation one that teases some very dark
and complicated themes in its opening
and one I was very excited to see
explored in Greater detail in this film
while the story did expand somewhat on
who this girl was to Utah and what their
deal was later on by the end it felt as
though that I knew other characters more
than I did the main character in Utah
and that's unfortunate while he
certainly has his moments I don't think
I ever felt personally connected to this
character of Utah enough for me to want
to follow him on this journey one of my
biggest issues I have with the main
story is that for the first half it
feels sort of aimless the film and
indeed manga very quickly established
what the goal is of course to remove
Rika from Yuta in order to allow him to
live in normal existence again free of
the horror she has brought onto his life
however there is a problem with this I
think once this is established there
isn't a clearer path forward for Yuta to
pursue no obvious series of events
needed to be satisfied that will solve
the issue at hand and meet that goal the
situation between Rika and Yuta is
tragic in every sense of the word and
indeed a compelling motivation to move
into a particular direction but we
aren't given much in the way of how
that's going to be achieved Beyond Utah
getting stronger and going to this
school now with that said while I was
expecting more from the introduction to
this character I was willing to wait and
see what the rest of the intro had to
offer it's not like shy characters are
inherently boring to me it's only one
dimension of a personality type a
character like him can have and often
times there are secondary aspects I can
latch onto midoriya or Deku from my hero
Academia was not only a character that
grew on me but by the end of his
introductory sequence had me in tears
like Yuta were shown plenty of
Misfortune in his life so much so that
once he does eventually receive some
encouragement he collapses to the floor
clutching at his chest crying there's
plenty of Misfortune there for me to
sympathize with but the moment that
connected me to the character was when
he chose to be brave now I'm connected
as well as sympathizing with this
character he's shy but he's also
tenacious virtuous and good and what I
can appreciate you to circumstances have
effectively beaten him down over many
years he still hasn't shown me enough to
get invested in his story specifically
Beyond just being sympathetic towards
towards it but if I ignore all that I
can appreciate just how different a
character like Yuta is for a story like
this one Shonen Jump is filled with
enthusiastic good boys trying to Take On
The World and in a way I did like that
this was trying to do something totally
different while Deku shows strength and
more obvious and easily relatable ways
Utah is a very troubled and emotionally
scared young man who was willing to take
his own life had he been given the
chance to by Eureka this does remove
agency from his character somewhat but
he did make a very difficult and brave
decision early on in the intro portion
when confronted by Gojo he was offered
two choices sit there alone forever or
come with him and try to do something
about his situation and while we haven't
seen anything this young man has been
through we do see the toll it has taken
on him and that alone is compelling and
given that he was able to pick himself
up from the depths of Despair one last
time to try to fix his situation it's
not difficult to see why so many people
might resonate with that character it's
just for me personally I would have
liked to have seen more from him as a
character beyond that one admirable and
brave Choice thankfully however the rest
of the cast is much more engaging and
gets to demonstrate their personalities
right away Maki clearly has a chip on
her shoulder offers a lot in the way of
capable fighting and even establishes
something of an emotional Journey for
herself in this opening sequence
additionally inumaki was a surprisingly
fun and engaging character despite him
not being able to speak clearly I never
would have thought that including a kid
that can speak to folks would have been
a good decision but all it does is offer
him compelling alternative to speech
while also making for some really cool
powers to help explain the world to us
visually and then there's panda
he's a panda
before we go any further I want to take
a moment to talk to you about one hell
of a huge game this thing has over 850
million players worldwide and has grown
to ludicrous proportions since its
initial launch in Korea in 2005. it is
of course dungeon Fighter online the de
facto free to play multiplayer hack and
slash online multiplayer RPG There are
16 unique characters to choose from and
those branch out into four or five
advancement classes these classes offer
fascinating fighting techniques and all
come with their own unique stories and
Concepts this means that there are over
60 different class advancements in the
game that's a crazy amount of content
and an almost guaranteed means of
finding a playstyle that works for you
there's a real commitment to longevity
here also with updates and events every
two weeks that introduce exciting new
rewards and content it's great for
jumping in as new players as these
events often allow for Speedy leveling
up to bring you on par with current
content for example if you jump in now
for the level up power-up event you'll
receive huge rewards and materials all
the best gear and at level 100 you'll
get a golden jumping capsule to
instantly skip to the game's current max
level of 110. it's super simple and
after that you simply log in a few times
a week for even more goodies at the
moment there's a new Awakening one sale
going on that offers you access to the
most sought after Avatar package in the
game it really is the best time to jump
in and you can do so by copying the
coupon code welcome to DFO gift you'll
get a funky Avatar set and some awesome
bonus items to get you started so if
that sounds great click the link in the
description and download today for free
as for the world and power system I
think the idea of having curses manifest
in places due to the negative
experiences of the people who are once
there is a great idea that ties nicely
into YouTube's story with his personal
curse that he's trying to get rid of the
mechanism by which they seal off areas
in these domes of energy and the designs
of the creatures that lurk within are
all fantastic to see and enjoy I have no
issues there and to be honest the action
concerning these encounters at this
school and thereafter is terrific seeing
and learning about the numbers game some
of the weaker curses play and of course
the stomach they all end up within to
save the two small children they arrive
to rescue in the first place it's all
handled tremendously well particularly
in how they highlight what Utah himself
is lacking and ultimately what Rika is
capable of when she's used correctly
the middle the middle or second act of a
film is largely dedicated to
establishing the main conflict or
antagonist and while Rika is technically
that for now with her not providing you
to the necessary pushback he needs to
unravel this problem he's having we need
another more active protagonist to push
this film in some sort of Direction and
thankfully we do eventually get that
however before we do once Utah arrives
in school due to there being no clear
path forward towards his established
goal all we can do as an audience is
sort of just sit back relax and go along
for the ride with Yuta and his
classmates as they take on different
enemies in different locations and
encounter some superbly animated action
sequences against curses and apparitions
the action in the film is brilliant and
you won't find any complaints from me in
that department the direction in this
film is Stellar from the animation to
the storyboards to the color used to
light different and more dramatic scenes
and did I mention the music there are
two insert songs in this film one at the
beginning as we get ready for our first
day at school with Utah and in indeed
the climax that I will get into just a
little bit from now but back on topic I
think of these opening scuffles it's the
mission Utah shares with inumaki that
hits hardest for me mostly because it
coincides with the narrative midpoint
and how it's used to actually give the
story Direction but firstly inumaki is
oddly a very endearing character one
that shares a lot and has a brilliantly
effective and dicey power I've gone on
the record in saying that my favorite
type of power is one that has obvious
and built-in drawbacks to use it like
okay think Kaio Cannon Dragon Ball are
deku's all for one power in my hero
Academia in this film inumaki has a very
powerful ability but it's due to its
consequences that strategy needs to be
employed and a palpable tension is
injected into each and every encounter
he participates in I love stuff like
this and furthermore we finally get some
direction through this curse that shows
up at the narrative midpoint I did
mention this moments ago but the
narrative midpoint is a very common
writing technique implemented in pretty
much every single story you can think of
of and typically it's used to story
you're watching interesting however in
this case it has the secondary effect of
finally giving the film Direction enter
suguru ghetto this guy shows up notices
that this film doesn't have a clear
story and says hey I want to set a new
world order based on my own internal
bigotry I'm a bad guy who wants to fight
me and everyone is like yeah okay enjoy
and just someone to attack in this
battle Shonen and actually have a means
of entertainingly arriving at the climax
of the story without Meandering with
Utah hopping from place to place gaining
experience now I want to be clear again
that I can totally see why someone would
connect with Yuta as a character
particularly if they themselves have
gone through some troubling times in
their life where they saw no way out the
strength he shows in his first meeting
with Gojo is not only admirable but
immeasurably Brave given how ready he
was to just give up on life and
everything in the first place and in a
way I can kind of understand how a story
that doesn't have a clear path to
success can further feed into making
that decision you to ultimately makes
all the more Brave due to the uncertain
and seemingly hopeless Road he's facing
thematically it works remarkably well
and in many ways succeeds in that regard
however it had for me the unfortunate
added effect of making the first half of
this film quite boring without something
to latch onto or follow it felt like we
were just going from one scene to the
next going through the motions until
suddenly ghetto shows up and finally
offers us something more to look forward
to and watch develop and I think that's
important for now we have something of a
goal to shoot for or at the very least
anticipate we can enjoy all the
positives which the character of Utah
provides with the pacing ghetto offers
the story which brings me to my final
Point concerning the midsection before I
start to talk about the big
action-filled climax ghetto is
exceptionally important for the pacing
of this film simply because before him
there was literally no one to drive the
story forward in storytelling there are
often two types of characters which
complement each other rather well active
and reactive characters active
characters are individuals which Drive
the plot forward through their actions
and choices they make think Walter White
approaching Jesse in episode 1 of
Breaking Bad to Kickstart his mission or
think of Eric Cartman from South Park
doing something truly horrendous forcing
those around him to have to pick up the
pieces with them integrated into the
scene or storyline you can rest assured
that whenever the plot lacks Direction
they will leap into action to help it
race towards some sort of conclusion
alternatively you have the reactive
character type and in the case of Utah
you have the reactive protagonist these
are characters whose entertainment value
comes not from what they project
outwards onto the world but instead how
they react to that world topi Maguire's
Spider-Man generally speaking is a great
example of such a character as the hero
it's his duty to react to the chaos and
solve the messes that the villains
around him create these types of
characters can be incredibly compelling
that's for certain and while both active
and reactive protagonists can and often
are in a lot of different stories it is
more often than not the reactive
protagonist that requires an active
Force to fight against without Green
Goblin or Dr Octopus Spider-Man's 1 and
2 would have sucked and so for the same
reason that without an active Force to
fight or react to in the first half of
this film it felt like the story was
sort of going through the motions and
once an active character did arrive
suddenly it felt like a film again or at
least that's how I saw it and from here
on in all honesty I had a lot of fun
with this film and so let's break down
the climax which I thoroughly enjoyed
the end just like choosing Utah as the
main character was an interesting
decision this film also makes it equally
interesting and oddly compelling choice
in making the antagonistic forces weaker
than the forces of good I've mentioned
before that I'm a fan of waketto offers
the story but I really mean it when I
say that the strategy he's forced to
employ makes him feel all the more
devious and clever with him being forced
to navigate and strategize around his
fewer forces in a successful manner it
acts not just as the perfect setup for
some fights but very quickly brings him
in contact with Utah which is exactly
what I wanted I love the way with which
ghetto manages to Corner Yuta and
everyone back at base I love that the
Shroud he encapsulates the area with
prevents communication to the outside
and I love the the role all the
supporting casts played in defending
Utah from this monster seriously Panda
and inumaki's team up was something to
behold in the anime and really elevated
the material that already existed in the
manga they didn't have that much of a
fight in the manga but in the anime it's
fantastic and very quickly became my
favorite action moment of the film but
it's the final fight between Yuta and
ghetto that becomes the fight to end all
fights within this film and the surprise
it enzyme not only offers a solution to
the conflict of the film but indeed
facilitates the answers that remedy
Utah's current circumstances making this
final third of the film comfortably the
best part and most cohesive part of the
narrative in my book at least the team
up of Yuta Enrique is nothing but
cathartic and frantically fun to watch
as the Young Troubled Boy comes to grips
more and more with his powers and in the
process becomes more and more aware of
what he's capable of and in truth he
sort of has all of these Powers through
Rika but it's in that overpoweredness
that grants gato his appeal for finding
the golden path forward and indeed Yuta
in learning to deal with what he is and
accepting the help of Rika working
together to take down this formidable
and intimidating foe both of these
characters bringing out the best in each
other with the climax of the fighting
seeing Utah effectively choosing to
offer himself up to Rika in order to
save everyone else it's a scary but
compelling contrast made to the very
first scene where in a desperate attempt
to protect everyone from himself he
tried and failed to take his own life
now while offering up his life once
again it's through embracing what he
once was so terrified of proving that
even the most terrifying and unsightly
parts of ourselves can yield positive
outcomes for everyone and that we if we
have the strength and resolve to do so
can move forward and make a difference
in this world if we choose to fight once
again Utah as a character and the
delivery of this idea is like I said at
the beginning the most impressive
narrative Choice made in this film and
how it's demonstrated is just as
fascinating with the climax of the fight
coming to an end and the monster that he
once feared now having melted away
thematically he's proven that he can
live a normal life and Rika will wait
for him and the twist that made all of
this possible was that he was the one
that put the curse on Rika and that was
a fantastic cherry on the top of this
brilliantly orchestrated narrative cake
and now that he set her free he too has
freed himself from the prison of his own
guilt and inability to move on and while
I can appreciate all of that I do still
find myself wishing that if this film
had fleshed out all of his character a
bit more towards the beginning of the
film that I might not have found the
first half as boring as I did
interestingly or perhaps tellingly
there's a page towards the end of this
manga where the author of Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen Gage akutami wrote about his
process when it came to writing stories
in it he said when I started a manga
series I don't really have a theme or
principles in mind I begin by thinking
about things like these twists would be
interesting or these characters might be
cool or this scene would be amazing now
I don't want to jump to conclusions and
I think it's fair to point out that the
mainline series probably doesn't suffer
from the same problems I thought this
film did but with a character like Yuta
and the horrific scene and circumstances
he's introduced with it seems like this
was a character unseen that akutami
wanted and thought would be cool to
write about but didn't consider how he
would later have that character navigate
the story in a meaningful way to the
next relevant plot beats later at the
end of that manga when talking about the
main line jiu jitu Kaizen series he goes
on to talk about how he has ideas for
scenes and endings but just doesn't know
how to connect the various ideas he has
in his head just yet and while I think
that's a fine approach for a more
well-versed writer that he could very
well be right now I think it was perhaps
that approach which made this first half
of the film as boring and and as aimless
as it seemed to me with that said
however this film had tons to appreciate
and I'd be lying if I said that going
back over my notes and analyzing this
film more and more hasn't already given
me a greater appreciation for it so
while I stand by all of my criticisms
I've given it thus far and think that
the film is plagued with creative
decisions that in large sections made it
a bore to watch and as I said at the
beginning a little too reliant on tropes
resulting in a rather uninspired path
towards a Finish Line that I did very
much like and despite me personally not
seeing it as anything more than a 6 out
of 10 I can absolutely see why someone
might give this film an 8 or a 9 if they
can connected to it in the right way and
who knows maybe if I watch the series
and revisit this film sometime down the
line I might have a different reaction
too but the question remains has this
story given me enough to capture my
interest has it enticed me to want to
pick up and review the first season of
the Jiu Jitsu Kaizen anime well I don't
know yet let me know what you think down
below and while you do I'll be
considering it but until then I hope you
will subscribe for more honest and
in-depth reviews like this and if you're
feeling so generous you can support me
over on patreon.com forward slash
totally not Mark take care everyone and
thank you all so much for watching
[Music]